there is a stunning new poll from
right-wing FoxNews showing that more
than half of Americans want Donald Trump
not just impeached but impeached and
removed from office now earlier this
week I told you about the new Washington
Post poll and that one said 60% of the
country agrees with the impeachment
inquiry and that support for the inquiry
has tripled among Republicans from about
10 percent to about 30 percent the Fox
News poll asks something else which is
do you believe that Donald Trump should
be impeached and removed and 51 percent
of Americans now say yes he should an
additional four percent say yes on
impeachment but not yet sure on the
removal this poll being from Fox News
will likely accelerate Donald Trump's
breakup with Fox News which we've been
tracking for a long time that's really
kind of a sad store a side story but
there is one interesting thing to
mention there remember how last week I
told you that former Republican Speaker
of the House Paul Ryan is now a board
member at Fox News there is speculation
people are saying as Donald Trump likes
to say there is speculation that it is
Paul Ryan's discussed with Donald Trump
that may actually be behind some of the
separation that we're seeing between Fox
and Trump recently which is an
interesting theory but a story for
another day
back to the polling truly devastating
numbers and and I want to talk about why
and I really want you to understand the
significance of these numbers I went
back and looked at polling from the
1970s Gallup was doing a lot of polling
of the Nixon White House in the 1970s
this was when the Watergate scandal was
ramping up for Richard Nixon and the
portion of the country that wanted Nixon
impeached remained quite low well into
the impeachment inquiry even when the
majority of the country already believed
Watergate is serious already believed
that Nixon was guilty of wrongdoing in
that only 26 percent of the country
believed that Richard Nixon should be
impeached and removed and Nixon remember
didn't have the benefit of a right-wing
media echo-chamber defending everything
that he'd
all the time this thing started two
weeks ago and more than half of the
country now believes that the president
should be removed from office in a Fox
News poll now there's another
interesting thing for most presidents
you gauge how things are going by
approval rating Trump's approval rating
has become completely secondary we are
now gauging how things are going by how
many people want Donald Trump impeached
and removed this is not normal the fact
that the focus now is not on approval
but on impeachment support means that
things are very different from the way
they normally are with American
presidents this is also by the way new
territory for Trump in that in business
when he's gotten into trouble he has the
escape hatch of bankruptcy and he's used
it he's pulled he's pulled the cord on
that escape hatch many times you can't
declare bankruptcy from what's going on
right now I guess the equivalent would
be resignation but were very very far
from that really being a discussion so
that being said a refusal to cooperate
with the impeachment inquiry makes him
look more guilty to normal people his
followers will resist that they'll say
no now he's doing the right thing it's a
witch hunt he's fighting it he's not
gonna bow down to the witch hunt but
even some Republicans are going to see
Trump's refusal to cooperate at all as a
sign of guilt Nixon tried to fight
impeachment
he lost Trump thinks he can fight it and
win he may be right a buddy may not now
let me throw something else at you about
the 51% wanting Donald Trump impeached
and removed Trump lost the popular vote
okay by a lot by more than any previous
president millions of votes this is now
being called a coup attempt by defenders
of Trump and by Trump himself this is a
coup to reverse the election results and
remove Donald Trump from office by the
very people who never voted for him in
the first place I went back and looked
every impeachment in history was called
a coup attempt by the defenders of the
president that was at risk of being
removed so that is another propaganda
technique made to once again
act from the facts and I encourage you
not to fall for it this is a
constitutionally enshrined mechanism to
investigate and adjudicate the
wrongdoing of a president it is not a
coup it's almost the opposite and it is
not a new thing every president facing
impeachment has had defenders say this
is an attempt at a coup it is not this
is how the system is designed